من ارتقاء الى عوامل نور العليا يعني رجل
دين
يريد ان يصعد الى مرتبه دينيه اعلى في
يقوم باجراءات دينيه في هذا المكان ااه
الشخص المتوفى الذي قتل او الذي لم ياخذ
الملابس الدينيه تجرى له طقوس ارتقاء في
هذا المكان
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للابناء الصعبه المندائيين هم
يقطنون مثل ما معروف للجميع انهم يقتنون
جنوب العراق منذ مئات السنين بالالاف
السنين همم
اخذت اعدادهم بالتناقص بحقيقه هي بدايه
الهجره من التسعينات تعرف انت بدايه عدم
استقرار العراق بدايه
انه العراق اخذ منحه جديد همم السياسه
العراقيه التي تاخذ من حاجه جديد همم
والنظره الدوليه للعراق بعد ذلك بدات
الهجره لكن بعدها قليله جدا لكن لا تكاد
ان تحسب لكن ال- ال- بدات الهجره الفعليه
والكبيره بعد
2003 حيث ان النظام
ده انهياره تعرف همم تغيرت همم امور كثيره
على طرات على الساحه العراقيه همم لا نقول
فقط السابع وانما الصابئه والايزيدين
والمسيحيين وكل الاقليات همم اخذوا
بالتناقص اعدادهم تتناقص في العراق وبعد
ان كانوا بيحسبونا بالمئات الالوف اصبحوا
يعدون بالالاف او اقل من ذلك
توجهنا الى مركز المندائيين الصابئه في
بغداد لنتعرف اكثر على التمثيل السياسي
لتلك الطائفه التقينا مع رئيس كتله
الصابئه المندائيين في العراق وهو النائب
البرلماني الوحيد عن هذه الطائف
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لنظام السياسي الجديد منذ عام
2003 الى الان لا تزال سياسه الاخصاب
والتهنيش بحق ابناء المكونات الصغيره
ومنها المكون من دعايه مستمره
الحكومات عاجزه
[موسيقى]
تطبيق مبدا التوازن والمساواه بين
المكونات جميعا وخصوص المكونات الصغيره
[موسيقى]
انه عدم ايمانهم بفكره اشتراك المكونات في
اداره الدوله السياسيه عامه